Let's go ahead and
create our application.
Start with a single view application,
we'll change this later, Next.
And make sure you don't
select Use Cored Data.
Even though we are going
to use Core Data,
if you select this Xcode will add a lot
of code to your application delegate.
And that's not the place where it
belongs, so don't select that and
we'll add this code manually later.
We'll call our application
coolnotesswift.
iPhone.
We're all set.
Now let's create a model for
our notes app.
The first step is to add data
model file to our project.
The default name is model, but
you can name it whatever you see fit.
Now, go ahead and create your own.
There seems to be three
things we can create here.
Entities, Fetch Requests,
and Configurations.
Let's start with entities.
Entities are a way of describing
the classes of your model.
Entities will be turn into
Swift classes by Xcode.
And this is actually the only
thing that we will create in here.
Fetch requests can also be
added to the data model.
However, I prefer to keep my
model as simple as possible, so
we'll create them for code.
Last but not least,
we have this configuration thing.
This is an extremely cool and
powerful tool in Core Data.
It allows us to save several
different stores at the same time.
For instance, a common combination
is to have a SQL store and
then in-memory store.
The latter behaves as a cache for
objects that might live in the cloud.
A configuration specifies to which
store each entity belongs to.
As you probably already guessed,
configurations are advanced Core Data.
So, let's set them aside for
the time being.
In the next video will start
creating some entities.